so let's start there I've talked about
how there are politician lies and liar
lies and there are kind of in-betweens
right so an example of a politician lie
would be under Obama saying that the a
particular type of GDP is growing less
slowly than some other kind and it's
sort of like a you know it's it's it
might be true to the letter but it
really misrepresents the spirit of what
we're measuring right that this would be
like a politician lie okay it's not
strictly speaking demonstrably false but
it's a distortion of what we usually
mean when we talk about that particular
issue Crump has made it a common aspect
a common tenet of his administration to
tell what we call liar lies just
straight-up demonstrable lies my
inauguration crowd was the biggest ever
for example or I never made a comment
about X when we have tweets and video of
him making a comment about X and then
there's a lot of in-betweens that relate
to economic data unemployment numbers
debt deficit all of these pieces of data
are really easy to mess with so that
you're maybe not lying by the letter but
you're definitely being deceptive in
spirit and on the issue of GDP gross
domestic product the Trump team is now
telling straight-up
unmitigated total lies about what's
going on so let's set this up first of
all what is GDP GDP is one measure of an
economy's growth or contraction GDP
stands for gross domestic product it is
calculated as the total value of goods
produced and services provided in a
country during one year how it's
calculated how imports and exports
impact it it's not really relevant for
our conversation today which is just
about lies and deception over the
weekend Donald Trump claimed 4.1% second
quarter GDP growth okay
that's where we'll start he had a whole
event it was all meant to talk about
four point one percent GDP growth
and Trump said a lot of other crazy
stuff during this event so let's take a
look at the video clip everywhere we
look we are seeing the effects of the
American economic miracle we have added
3.7 million new jobs since the election
a number that is unthinkable if you go
back to the campaign nobody would have
said it nobody would have even in an
optimistic way projected it we are in
the midst of the longest positive job
growth streak in history so almost
everything that Donald Trump said there
is simply not true but I want to focus
in a little bit on the GDP numbers this
GDP number has become sort of the
central point of a ton of Lies for the
last five or six days so here's an
example Donald Trump jr. on Twitter
tweeted incredible numbers I remember
when the experts laughed about breaking
3% just because Obama never broke 2%
doesn't mean that someone with great
policies can't let's keep this going
that's a straight-up unmitigated lie
under President Barack Obama GDP growth
broke 2% 16 times it broke three percent
eight times it hit four percent four
times and it was actually 5% on one
occasion what Donald Trump jr. is saying
what Donald Trump himself and his
cronies are touting that this is unheard
of nobody would have even thought about
it well maybe people weren't thinking
about it because it wasn't that notable
because Obama did 5% once and 4% four
times and so on and so forth and as
usual a single quarter of 4.1% you've
got to think about why is that happening
Donald Trump says four point one percent
GDP growth is sustainable is it actually
sustainable is it because the business
environment is improving in some macro
way that we had 4.1 percent GDP growth
or is it because of underlying factors
that are actually concerning let me give
you an example we know about these
tariffs the tariffs are
being up many have been already enacted
more are coming
one possible explanation as to why GDP
was up 4.1 percent in this particular
quarter could be because manufacturers
are stocking up on materials from other
countries because of Donald Trump's
trade war and that on the backside of
this there's going to be a sharp
downturn that's a possibility right of
course
if the economy were really that strong
you might in addition to GDP growth see
wage growth but you're not seeing it and
in fact that's a problem that's bigger
than Donald Trump but it continues to
indicate that in many ways the economy
is not doing that well is maybe the
stock market would suggest so this isn't
about me wanting to deny that four point
one percent is a good GDP number on
paper this is to point out that first
and foremost the idea that these are
unheard of GDP growth numbers under
Obama that's a total straight-up
farcical lie I mean flat out it's just a
lie but number two just like I've
described to you that the labor force
could shrink because there's a bad
economy but the labor force could also
shrink because people can afford to
retire which implies a good economy
right just the number itself doesn't
really tell you what's going on
underlying the economy and in that same
way a single quarter of higher GDP
growth could be because of some negative
indicators and it could be because of
some positive indicators as well the
problem is nobody understands no one
seems to care to understand and Trump
himself lacks the basic understanding of
economics on this stuff and we've talked
about this on trade Trump knowing very
little about trade started talking about
trade unfair trade and so on during the
campaign his supporters fell for it and
all of a sudden now Trump has basically
free reign to make terrible decisions
when it comes to trade like the trade
war in the same way Trump has been
successful at touting GDP growth numbers
in a total vacuum with no context or
consideration for what's going on in the
economy and it works really really well
and what I'm trying to do is to give you
just a little bit more
information about how we should
understand some of that data today's
program sponsored in part by blinkers
comm slash Pakman I've talked about
blinkers before it's this awesome app
that I've been using for several months
now and what it does is take the best
and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is
t-dot-com slash PA k ma n